Professor Mark Saltzman:
This week we're going to
talk about renal physiology.
Renal is kidney physiology,
the study of the function of
kidneys.
We're going to talk mainly
about how they work when they're
working correctly and what
functions they perform in the
body.
You probably know that they're
important, but hopefully by the
end of the lecture today,
you'll know exactly why they
are so important for your
overall state of health.
You won't live very long
without near normal kidney
function.
The reading on this is Chapter
9 and in section we'll talk
about a biomedical engineering
innovation that over the last 50
or 60 years or so has really
changed the quality and duration
of life for patients that have
kidney disease,
and that's kidney dialysis or
renal dialysis.
We'll talk about that on
Thursday afternoon.
This is just an outline of
the things that we're going to
cover during the lecture today,
and on Thursday.
We're going to talk about sort
of just gross aspects of the
urinary system,
the kidney, the bladder,
and the tubes that connect
these things.
I'll talk a little bit about
the differences between plasma;
plasma is the fluid that
circulates in your body.
We thought about circulation of
fluids in the body the week
before spring break.
We talked about the heart and
the blood vessels and the blood,
and so the main fluid of
interest there was plasma,
this fluid that blood cells
circulate in.
The main fluid we'll be
interested in renal physiology
is urine.
This is a fluid that's produced
by the kidneys,
stored in the bladder,
and then excreted from the body
and it's one of the primary
mechanisms that your body has
for getting rid of waste and
regulating the composition of
fluids like plasma.
I'll talk a little bit more
about that in just a second.
To understand how it works
we'll talk about the anatomy of
the kidney on the gross level
and on the microscopic level.
It has an amazingly
sophisticated organization which
is critical for its function.
So, if you understand the
anatomy of the kidney,
you understand a lot about how
it works.
Then we'll talk about specific
about how urine is created in
the kidney process.
It turns out that all of these
processes are important for
maintaining your health.
As I mentioned we'll talk
lastly about dialysis which is
an extraordinarily effective,
but not quite perfect means for
keeping people that have kidney
failure in good health.
I've shown you a picture
like this, maybe exactly this
picture or a picture like this
before,
but this is sort of a block
diagram or an engineering view
of the human body.
You can see the outside world
is the things that surround this
red and blue labeled box and the
inside of the body is inside.
We talked--last time we were
here, we talked about the
circulatory system and so this
mechanism for circulating fluids
around in the body.
We talked about how that works
and why that's so important.
You'll remember that when
we talked about the nervous
system which controls a lot of
body functions.
We talked about,
both in the nervous system and
in the cardiovascular system,
how important certain ions were
for the function of those cells.
In particular,
we talked about sodium and
potassium.
Sodium and potassium,
which are present--in the case
of sodium at high concentration
outside of cells,
low concentration inside,
potassium the reverse;
high concentration inside,
low concentration outside.
In order for those cells to
function for a nerve cell to
send a signal down an axon or
for a cardiac muscle cell to
contract,
those concentrations of ions
have to be present and they have
to be the way that I've
described.
You have to have high
extracellular sodium,
low intracellular--high
intracellular,
potassium low extracellular.
If your sodium and potassium
levels are not correct you can't
make an action potential in the
way that we've described before;
heart doesn't beat,
brains can't send signals.
All of that physiology we
talked about in the nervous
system and the heart depends on
having ion concentrations in
your body at the correct level.
How is that maintained?
Well, one way you could
maintain--you could think about
it, if you have a box like this,
if this is your body,
you could think about
maintaining it by just knowing
exactly how much sodium and
potassium to eat everyday so
that you always keep the right
amount,
and you're going to lose some,
you lose some fluids.
So, if you knew exactly how
much to eat you could regulate
concentration that way.
That would be--that's difficult
to do and you know we don't do
that.
We eat, in general,
excess sodium and excess
potassium.
Somehow our body is keeping
these concentrations at the
right level.
How does it do that?
Well, that's really the main
function of the kidney.
The main function of the
kidney is to sense how much
sodium and potassium there is in
your body and then to extract
the amount that's not needed in
order to maintain the levels at
the constant concentration
that's needed.
The main function of the
urinary system,
which is shown as this part of
the diagram over here,
is to detect what's in the
plasma, what's in the blood.
Think about it in terms of
sodium and potassium
concentrations,
but there are many,
many other elements that are
also controlled.
It detects what's there and it
removes what's not needed.
That is, it removes what is in
excess of what you need to have
the proper concentration.
Now, you could imagine
doing that in two ways.
Let's just think about sodium
concentrations for--if your
sodium concentration is too high
so it needs to come down,
then the kidney could either
excrete more sodium or excrete
less water.
You know that the kidney gets
rid of waste by getting rid of
urine, and urine is mostly
water.
So, you can control
concentration in the body by
either changing how much of the
molecule you keep or how much
water you retain or how much
water you lose.
All of these things are linked
together in some way.
The kidneys sit here in
intimate contact with the
circulatory system,
we'll talk about that.
In order to perform this
function of regulating
concentrations of things in the
blood, it needs to see a lot of
blood.
Blood flow to the kidney is
essential and you'll see that
its anatomy puts it in a good
position to see a lot of the
blood flow.
Then it does some
transformations,
it does some functions we'll
talk about over the course of
the next couple of days,
it then produces a fluid called
urine.
You have a reservoir for urine
in your body called the bladder.
That's basically just a storage
vessel for urine that's produced
by the kidneys,
and then you excrete that.
What's in the excreted fluid
urine?
Mainly water,
salts, and organic wastes.
Now, what organic wastes
are eliminated by the kidneys?
Well, think about metabolism;
you're breaking down sugars,
you're breaking down proteins,
you're using those raw
materials to build other
molecules but there are waste
products of that process of
breaking down and building back
up molecules.
A waste product of sugar
metabolism is carbon dioxide,
where it is the final form of
carbon in the body is carbon
dioxide.
You get rid of that not in the
kidney largely,
but mainly in the lung by
breathing out CO_2.
The main product of nitrogen
metabolism--and where does
nitrogen come from?
It comes from proteins that we
eat.
In the Western world,
in developed worlds,
we eat a lot more protein than
we need for building new
proteins.
We have protein rich diets,
and so you have a lot of waste
products from proteins that
accumulate.
In particular,
the waste product of nitrogen,
and all amino acids have
nitrogen.
The end product of metabolism
of amino acids or proteins is a
molecule called urea.
Urea is an example of an
abundant organic waste that's
eliminated by the kidneys.
It's not volatile,
it's not a gas like carbon
dioxide, so you can't breathe it
out.
It has to be eliminated in
water and it's concentrated in
the urine.
If concentrations of urea get
to high in your plasma,
it becomes toxic.
One of the main functions of
the kidney is to get rid of
end-products of nitrogen
metabolism like urea,
to keep the levels low enough
that they don't cause any
toxicity.
That's a couple of--as you
can see very important functions
for the kidney.
Getting rid of waste product of
natural metabolism that would
otherwise be toxic to the body,
that's urea,
and regulating the
concentrations of ions like
sodium and potassium.
We could add calcium,
and phosphate,
and magnesium,
but regulating the
concentrations primarily of
sodium and potassium so that the
other organs in your body can
function in the right way.
We call that function
maintaining the internal
environment, maintaining the
internal milieu,
maintaining the internal fluid
composition at some constant
level so that the other organs
can function properly.
Let's think about the
anatomy a little bit,
and it's shown on this slide.
The words on the top of the
slide just tell you what I
already told you.
You know probably that your
kidneys--you have two of them
and--one of the left and one on
the right and they set sort of
right below your ribcage in the
back.
They're in the back part of
your abdominal cavity,
a space that's called the retro
peritoneal position in your
body.
If you remember from the
circulatory system,
the heart is right here,
the heart is in the center,
slightly to the left side of
the chest.
Coming out of the heart,
the cardiac output comes out
through the aorta,
and the aorta is initially
directed upwards and then it
curves and goes down through the
abdomen here.
If I trace the path of the
aorta, it starts in the thorax
between the lungs,
moves down here,
crosses through the diaphragm
and into the abdominal space,
so this is the abdominal aorta.
You can see that the kidneys
are positioned on either side of
the abdominal aorta.
Now, the flow through the
abdominal aorta is quite high.
This is one of the main vessels
and there are some branch points
before it gets there so there is
some blood that goes up to the
head and the upper parts of the
body,
but the major portion of the
cardiac output flows down your
abdominal aorta.
There are two main branches off
the abdominal aorta right here
called the renal arteries.
The renal arteries feed blood
to the kidneys directly.
The kidney is in a great
anatomical position to receive a
lot of the blood flow,
and it does.
This might vary minute to
minute depending on your state
of health and your level of
activity but it receives on
average about 25% of the cardiac
output.
Cardiac output was--remember
what the cardiac output number
was?
A good number to keep in your
head, 5 L/min,
and so it's receiving over 1
L/min of blood;
each of the kidneys are,
so that's a lot.
If blood goes in,
blood has to come back out.
It comes back out through two
renal veins, one from each
kidney which carries the blood
back to the vena cava and then
back up to the heart.
The kidney is in a privileged
position with respect to the
circulatory system so that it
can receive a lot of the flow.
The blood vessels aren't shown
on this diagram because I wanted
to make it clear in this diagram
what are the--all the components
of the urinary system but you
can see the renal artery.
This is the blow up of the
kidney over here,
a cross-section so you can see
inside.
The kidney is,
not surprisingly,
kidney-shaped and so it kind of
wraps around this central core.
In the central core here's the
renal artery which is bringing
blood in, the one labeled '4'
here,
the renal vein which is taking
blood out is labeled number 5.
Inside, that renal artery
splits into many smaller
arteries which spread this blood
flow throughout the bulk of the
kidney.
The renal vein carries blood
back out and back to the vena
cava, as I mentioned.
Now, there's one other
vessel which emerges from this
section of the kidney and this
is called the ureter,
labeled number 6 here.
This the vessel through which
urine flows.
That urine flows out of the
kidney and then down,
down--you can see this ureter,
one from each kidney,
flowing down into this sac
called the bladder.
Then, the bladder has another
vessel which connects to the
outside world called the
urethra.
Urine is produced continuously
by the kidneys,
urine is continuously flowing,
although the rate might change
with time.
It's continually flowing into
the bladder, the bladder is an
expandable reservoir.
It expands, collects urine
until you're ready to release
it.
Then it's released through the
urethra to the external
environment;
so you have a picture of the
anatomy.
There are a couple of
functions I didn't talk about
and we won't talk about really
in our time on this subject.
The kidney also has a very
important function in regulating
blood pressure and we won't talk
about that.
It also secretes some hormones
that aid in red blood cell
production.
There's some other functions
aside from the ones we talked
about, but I'm going to talk
about the main ones I've
emphasized already.
You have a picture for the
anatomy of the kidneys and where
they sit.
You will remember that for each
kidney, now, we'll just assume
that they're each identical for
the rest of our discussion
today.
For each kidney there's blood
coming in, there's blood going
out, and there's urine coming
out.
One way,
and we've talked about this a
little bit before,
but if you're an engineer just
trying to analyze this system,
our question was how does the
kidney do what it does?
One way to try to understand
what it does is to treat it very
simply.
Let's just say it's a black
box, I don't really know
anything about what goes on
inside.
What I know about is that there
are flows going in and out:
there's the renal artery that
flows in,
there's the renal vein that
flows out, and there's the
ureter which carries urine away.
Let's just look at what goes in
and what comes out and see what
we could learn about the
function of the organ or what it
must do just by looking at those
inputs and outputs.
This is a common mode of
engineering analysis.
If we looked more carefully
at what's flowing into the
kidney there's blood and flows
through.
I mentioned a lot of blood goes
through the kidney at an
astonishing rate,
that each of your two kidneys
receives 1,
700 liters of blood per day
which flows continuously from
the aorta into the renal
arteries.
Of that, the blood is composed
of blood cells and plasma,
so if we just looked at the
plasma about half of that volume
slightly more than half of that
volume is plasma.
What's in plasma?
Mainly water,
proteins like albumin and
antibodies, and salts like
sodium and potassium
bicarbonate, and waste products
like urea.
If we measured what the
concentration was the average
concentration of each of those
things in the renal arteries,
we could calculate how much
flows in everyday.
Plasma, 950 liters per day,
that's almost 1,000 liters of
water per day flows through your
kidneys;
133 mmoles of sodium per day.
Less potassium per day because
there's less
potassium--concentration of
sodium is high,
potassium is low in the
extracellular fluid;
a lot of bicarbonate,
the main pH buffer in the
blood, and quite a lot of urea,
500 grams of urea.
Remember this is a waste
product so your body needs to
get rid of this,
so that's what's flowing in to
each kidney.
What comes out we could
think about analyzing by looking
at what comes out in the urine.
If we collected the urine and
measured the concentrations,
what comes out is about 1.5
liters per day of water,
of fluid volume.
What comes out in terms of
sodium?
About 103 mmoles per day,
so of the 133,000 mmoles of
sodium that go through the
kidneys each day your kidney
gets rid of about 100 mmoles.
So, it's looking at a lot of
sodium, figuring out how much
you need, and then excreting the
little bit of excess that you
have because of excess that
comes in in your diet generally.
We eat more salt than we need
to keep alive.
With potassium,
50 mmoles per day,
so it's still a small fraction
of what comes through,
bicarbonate,
small fraction of what comes
through, and urea--now there's a
lot,
52 compared to 475,
so a sizeable fraction of the
urea gets eliminated every day.
Now, these numbers that are
percentages over here,
what I did was I just took the
total amount that you eliminate,
the total amount that's
eliminated, so 1.5 liters per
day and figured out what
percentage that was of the total
water that the kidney sees
everyday;
so 1.5 liters per day is .16%
of 950 liters per day.
Your kidney excretes .1%--.16%
of the water that flows through
it, a pretty small fraction,
a similar small fraction of
sodium, more of potassium,
much less of bicarbonate,
and 11% of the urea that goes
through.
How could the kidney do this?
How did the kidney do this?
You probably know something,
how does the kidney work?
How does it separate the
molecules that it wants to
excrete from all of the
molecules that are passing
through here?
What must this look like inside
in order to accomplish this
task?
You can learn a lot about it
just by looking at these
numbers.
How does it work?
Student:
Osmosis?Professor Mark
Saltzman: Osmosis or--what's
osmosis?
Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: It's--osmosis is
separation across a membrane,
where you have a semi-permeable
membrane and that's a good idea.
There is osmosis that goes on
and we're going to talk about
it.
Osmosis is a really critical
way that the kidney functions at
the microscopic level and we'll
talk about that.
There's another sort of more
cruder level of function that
I'm thinking about,
or a simpler level of function.
How do--what was your vision of
how the kidney worked when you
came in here?
What does your kidney do?
Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Filters?
It's a filter.
How do filters work?
How does a filter work?
Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: A filter works
because it has some property
that if you put a liquid on top
of it,
some of the components of the
liquid will pass through and
some of them won't.
Generally when you think about
filters what physical principle
does it use to keep things on
one side or to decide what
passes through?
What property of molecules?
Size, generally filters work
based on size,
they're mechanical and they
have holes in them and those
holes are of a certain size and
so only molecules that are
smaller than that size can pass
through.
Now, that would make sense
for the kidney because what's in
the blood that you don't want to
pass through?
You don't want blood cells to
pass through and those are
large, those are 5 or 10 microns
in diameter.
You don't want those to pass
through so let's have a filter
that keeps blood cells on one
side and only allows things that
are smaller than blood cells to
go through.
You also have proteins in your
blood and those are generally
large molecules.
You have albumin,
you have antibodies,
you have lots of lipoproteins,
you have insulin,
you have lots of proteins that
are in the blood and those have
important functions inside your
body.
They're hard to make,
you don't want to lose them,
and in general,
the filter is such that
proteins don't go through.
Small molecules can go
through, glucose can go through,
and it's a much smaller
molecule.
Do you want glucose to go
through?
In fact, I haven't even listed
it here, would you want glucose
to go through?
Probably not because you worked
hard to gather your food and eat
it, and you want to extract the
energy from glucose,
you don't want to lose a lot of
it so you'd like to keep that
in.
It's a small molecule;
in fact, it's not so much
bigger than urea or sodium,
or potassium,
or bicarbonate.
These are all fairly small
molecules.
They all pass very easily
through the filter.
If your kidney was just a
filter what would you expect to
see in the urine?
In particular,
what would these percentages be
if the kidney acts as a filter?
If I tell you that all of these
molecules are smaller--are small
enough to pass freely through
the kidney filter?
Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Higher
or--Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Well they'd all be
the same,
right?
They'd all be the same
percentage.
If the kidney was just a filter
and everything passed through
that was smaller than a certain
amount,
then what you should see in the
urine is just the same--exact
same percentage in the urine as
is in the plasma.
If your kidney was just a
filter and it just allowed urea,
and bicarbonate,
and potassium,
and sodium, and water to pass
through then you should have the
same fraction of water,
etc.
These percentages wouldn't be
different;
they'd be whatever they needed
to be.
Now, what's the most
important thing here?
Getting rid of the toxic
compound, got to get rid of the
toxic compound otherwise you get
sick.
If the kidney was just a filter
and I needed to get rid of 11%
of the urea, then I would have
to also lose 11% of the water.
In a simple filter,
if I want to get rid of 11% of
the urea, and the urea is
dissolved in water,
they both pass through the
filter then I'd have to get rid
of 11% of the water.
Let's say 11% is about 100
times this, 100 x .16% so that
would mean this number has to be
100 liters per day.
What's the problem with
having a urine output of 100
liters per day?
That's a lot.
Could you sit through a class
that's 50 minutes long?
Probably not;
is there a 1 liter bottle?
How big is--that's probably
bigger than a liter right?
Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Just about a
liter;
so you would pee 100 of those
per day, so your bladder is--can
be a pretty good size but it's
not big enough to hold 100
liters,
your body is not that big.
A problem, if your kidney was a
simple filter,
is that you would have to be
losing water,
excreting water all the time.
The flip side of that is for
you not to shrink you've got to
be consuming that amount of
water.
If the kidney was a simple
filter and you needed to get rid
of urea, and assuming that these
numbers are appropriate numbers
for--then you would have to pee
out over 100 liters per day and
you have to drink 100 liters of
water per day in order to
maintain your volume.
What happens if you lose
too much volume?
Then your ion concentrations go
out of whack as well because
they're not dissolved in the
right volume of water.
Your kidney must have some
other mechanism besides being a
filter.
In particular,
it has to recover things that
you need.
Filtration is an important part
of it, but it also has to be
selective in some way,
and filtration is not selective
enough.
Filtration is not selective
enough because there are lots of
molecules that are about the
same size,
some that are toxic,
and some that are essential for
health, and you can't separate
them just based on size.
Just another example of
that if we looked--another way
to look at how the kidney works
is to look at relative
concentrations in the plasma and
the urine.
Ordinarily, the kidney is very,
very good at keeping glucose
out of the urine.
Even though it's a small
molecule, it gets filtered along
with urea, the kidney saves it
somehow so that it's abnormal to
have any urine in your--any
glucose in your urine even
though you have high
concentrations in the plasma.
You get rid of quite a lot of
sodium, a tremendous amount of
urea as we mentioned,
and creatine is another waste
product that turns out to be
important for reasons we won't
really talk about very much.
How does it work if it's
not just a simple filter?
Well, filtration is an
important part of it,
so filtration occurs in the
kidney,
it's the initial separation
that happens where molecules
that your kidney is processing
gets separated from the blood
plasma.
Filtration is the important
first step and I'll talk about
that in a few moments.
This filtration does not
directly produce urine.
You know what the problem with
that is, it's you'd have to
produce too much urine if that
was the only thing that
happened.
Instead, the kidney reabsorbs,
so after the filtration step it
takes the fluid that's produced
by filtration and it looks at
that fluid and it decides what
things the body can use,
water, glucose,
sodium, potassium,
and it reabsorbs them back into
the blood.
Filtration is the first
function, re-absorption is the
second function.
If you're filtering 100 liters
per day and you're only creating
1 liter of urine that means that
there's a lot of re-absorption
going on.
Most of the water that gets
filtered through the kidney gets
reabsorbed, only that small
fraction, .1% gets excreted in
urine.
We're going to call the
filtrate, or the fluid that gets
produced by filtration,
that's fluid that wants to be
urine.
It wants to be urine someday
but it's--that's what it aspires
too, it aspires to be urine but
it's not quite urine yet.
The important role of the
kidney is to make that--is to
extract back out the fluids that
are in this sort of want-to-be
urine the things that it can use
to produce a very concentrated
waste stream.
The kidney also directly
secretes some compounds,
so there's some compounds that
aren't filtered very effectively
or as effectively as we need
them to be.
The kidney has mechanisms for
taking molecules directly from
the blood and pumping them into
the urine.
That's a little--that's a
specialized function that's a
little bit beyond where we need
to go.
I wanted to show it to you
for--where we have time to go I
wanted to show it to you for
completion.
If you go on to study
physiology you'll learn a lot
about this.
There's filtration,
re-absorption,
this accounts for the majority
of what happens in terms of
processing to form urine,
but there's also secretion,
and then finally the urine that
goes to the bladder and is
eliminated.
Just coming back to this
picture again,
the renal arteries,
about 180 liters of that fluid
that comes in per day is
filtered.
This is about 900 and some
liters of plasma that goes into
the kidneys.
Of that, 180 liters are
filtered, meaning that whatever
the filter portion of the kidney
is 180 of those liters,
or a fairly substantial
fraction, passes through the
filter.
You only lose about 1.5 liters
per day of urine and that means
that the kidney is reabsorbing
178.5 liters per day.
That's an astounding amount of
work, both to filter this
quantity of fluid and then
recover that fluid back,
takes a lot of energy and we'll
see that there's a lot of action
that's going on inside the cells
of the kidney to allow this to
happen.
You should be very grateful
because if your kidney did not
do this work for you then there
are a lot of activities that you
would have trouble participating
in if you had to be constantly
worried about peeing and
drinking,
you couldn't wait to do it
because you've got to do it all
the time in order to maintain
this balance life would be very
different.
This is the problem when the
kidneys begin to fail.
If you're not filtering,
secreting, and reabsorbing this
much water which the kidneys do
through very active energy
consuming processes,
then what happens?
Concentration of urea goes up,
concentration of sodium and
potassium gets out of whack,
and your health very quickly
deteriorates.
You cannot live a healthy life
very long without all of these
things happening continuously.
How does the kidney
accomplish these functions?
It accomplishes it through a
marvelously elegant machine
called the nephron,
and the nephron is the
functional unit of the kidney.
I'm going to show you in a
diagram in a moment,
this is sort of the picture,
a cartoon of the kidney if you
turned it on its side,
it's sitting up this way and
its kidney bean shaped.
I turned it on its side,
so this part at the capsule is
pointing up and it's up here,
and the inner part or the
medulla, the part where all the
vessels come in is pointing
down.
Oriented within each kidney are
a million, over a million of
these functional units called
nephrons.
Nephrons are just a series of
tubes that are arranged in a
very specific configuration.
We'll see in the next slide
that nephrons look slightly
different, there are
nephrons--of these million there
are different populations that
look slightly different but they
all have the same basic anatomy.
I'll just trace through the
anatomy here starting at this
little tuft at the top of the
nephron or near the top of the
nephron,
so near the capsule is a
structure called the glomerulus.
The glomerulus is where the
blood-carrying tubes and the
urine-carrying tubes meet.
The glomerulus is where these
two sets of tubules meet.
The glomerulus is the structure
in which filtration takes place.
What you see here is a ball
which is basically a sac.
You imagine a sac that is
enclosing sort of a tuft or a
tumbleweed of blood vessels.
There's blood that's coming
into this tuft of capillaries
and there's blood that's going
out.
You can't really see it here
but there's blood that's coming
in, there's blood that's going
out.
Each of these tufts is really a
branch of the renal artery.
I showed you the picture,
the renal artery comes in,
it branches,
it branches a million times and
there--one of those million
branches goes to each glomerulus
and it forms a tuft of
capillaries there.
This capillary is surrounded by
a sac, the capillary comes in,
and it's surrounded by a sac.
Filtration occurs across
these capillary walls.
How does filtration occur?
Filtration occurs by a pressure
drop, so the same physical force
that's moving blood through your
circulatory system.
We talked about blood pressure
generated by your heart,
and within this tuft of
capillaries this blood is
pressurized.
It's pressurized because it's
not that far from your heart.
There's not that much
resistance between where
pressure is formed in your heart
and this tuft.
In the sac outside is a low
pressure.
Now, this is a different kind
of a pressure drop because we've
been thinking about a pressure
drop along a tube,
high pressure here,
low pressure here,
and so fluid flows through the
tube.
Instead, now we have high
pressure inside of a tuft of
capillaries and low pressure
outside,
so the pressure drop is not
along the tube it's across the
wall of the tube.
If there's a pressure drop
across the wall of the tube and
the wall is leaky then water can
move across,
so it moves from inside the
tube to outside,
high pressure inside the tube,
low pressure outside.
This is where the
filtration function of the
kidney takes place,
in the capillaries of the
glomerulus.
The capillaries of the
glomerulus are leaky,
there are holes in them,
and so if there's high pressure
on the inside,
low pressure on the outside,
fluid can flow through and
anything that's small enough to
fit through these holes can pass
through with the fluid.
That 100 liters per day that's
filtered occurs in these one
million glomeruli of the one
million nephron in each kidney.
The space that's in this sac
here is where the first
differences between urine and
plasma are created.
The fluid that accumulates in
this sac outside the glomerulus
by filtration is different from
plasma.
It's different from plasma in
what way?
Well, it only has molecules
that are small enough to pass
through the filter and so it
only has molecules that are
below a certain size.
Plasma has blood cells,
it has red blood cells,
has white blood cells,
has proteins,
glucose, ions,
but the urine only has things
that are smaller than a certain
size.
Imagine a cut off in molecular
weight and everything that's
below that is present;
everything that's above is not
present.
How does the concentration
of sodium in the glomerulus
compare to the concentration of
sodium in this space--in this
want-to-be urine space?
Well, the concentration is the
same at this point because what
you have here is just a
filtrate.
If the molecule is very small
like water, or like sodium,
then all the molecules are
going to pass through;
there won't be any difference
in concentration on either side
of the filter.
What does this fluid look like
at this point of the tube of the
beginning of the urine flow
pathway?
It looks like what's called an
ultra-filtrate of plasma.
It looks like plasma but with
just the big molecules,
the big stuff removed.
The concentration of everything
else would be the same.
Does that make sense?
After filtration,
this fluid passes through this
winding set of tubes,
these winding set of tubules;
these are called the kidney
tubules.
This is not blood that's
flowing through here now,
but this is the fluid that
wants to be urine.
It flows through--these tubules
in the kidney are divided into
segments.
The first segment is called the
proximal convoluted tubule.
It's called convoluted because
it twists around,
it's proximal because proximal
means near, and this part of the
tube is near the glomerulus.
Proximal convoluted tubule,
the fluid flows through;
it flows down this loop and
this loop extends from the top
near the cortex of the kidney
down toward the medulla and then
up again.
There's a loop and this loop is
called the Loop of Henle,
after an anatomist who
described it first,
so it's called the Loop of
Henle.
Then there's another region
here which is another twisting,
winding tubule,
another convoluted tubule but
it's far from the glomerulus,
so this is called the distal
convoluted tubule.
Finally that distal convoluted
tubule flows into a straight
duct that goes down through the
medulla called the collecting
duct.
This collecting duct dumps
directly into the ureter which
carries urine to the bladder.
There's a lot of action
here.
The--an ultra-filtrate of
plasma is formed in this space,
this space by the way is called
Bowman's space,
after another anatomist who
first discovered it,
the space where the filtration
occurs into is called Bowman's
space.
The urine flows through the
distal convoluted tubule,
through the Loop of Henle--I'm
sorry,
through the proximal convoluted
tubule, down the Loop of Henle,
back up the Loop of Henle,
through the distal prox--distal
convoluted tubule into the
collecting duct and then out to
the ureter and the bladder.
Now, what's happening?
Why this complicated series of
tubes arranged in this way?
Actually, if we looked at the
microscopic anatomy in each of
these tubes, that's what's shown
here,
is what do the cells look like
that form these tubes at
different regions of the
nephron?
One thing that you could
notice, and that anatomists
noticed when they started
studying the kidney,
is that these tubes all
look--these tubes are all
composed of cells that look
slightly different.
The reason that they look
slightly different is because
they're performing different
functions.
The details of the functions
that they're performing are
beyond the scope of what we're
going to talk about,
or you'll be responsible for,
I'll mention a few of them.
One way to think about is that
different parts of the tubule
have different functions in
terms of re-absorption of
molecules from the urine.
The main task of the nephron,
after this filtration step,
is to recover the things that
the body still needs,
to recover sodium,
to recover glucose,
to recover potassium,
and to recover most importantly
water so that you don't have to
be drinking constantly in order
to remain healthy.
Different parts of the tubule
are responsible for different
elements of that re-absorption
process.
It turns out it's not quite
so simple as that.
You couldn't say glucose is
here, sodium's here,
potassium's here,
it's not quite that separated
but they function in sort of a
coordination in order to
accomplish this overall process
with each part of the tubule
performing slightly different
functions to do that.
Here's the picture that I
promised earlier,
where I just wanted to show you
what I've been showing you,
the kidney turned on its side.
Here you'd be laying down on
your side I guess and the
abdominal aorta's coming down
here,
blood flowing up to this
kidney, here's the capsule,
here's the medulla,
and here's all the nephrons
arranged in this up and down
pattern along the breadth of the
kidney.
This just shows that there are
glomeruli, these small tufts
everywhere throughout this upper
region of the kidney,
that there are--that all of
these glomeruli are branches of
a branch of the renal artery,
and that nephrons,
you can see in the cartoon I
showed you before,
here's one nephron shown,
here's the glomerulus,
and here's the proximal
convoluted tubule.
You can see in this more
elaborate drawing just how
convoluted it is.
There are many,
many--these are quite long
tubules, so there's a long
pathway for fluid to flow
through.
That's in order to give the
kidney cells time to perform
this function on all of the
fluid that's flowing through the
kidney.
This is kind of a
complicated picture and I'll let
you look at it at your leisure.
These are posted on the Classes
Server.
What I want to show you mainly
is this figure down here.
This is a picture of the filter
in the kidney.
Where does the filter reside in
the kidney?
It's at the--it's the
capillaries;
it's the walls of these
capillaries that form these
tufts in the glomerulus.
This picture is a scanning
electron micrograph that was
taken by--by taking one of these
capillaries,
cutting it open,
and then spreading it out so
you could look down on the
surface.
Here we're like looking from
the--actually from the outside
of the tube in and what you see
is holes.
These are physical holes that
are of a size that allows small
molecules to pass through but
keep blood cells and large
molecules on the other side.
The kidney really is a filter
in an important sense and it
functions just like a coffee
filter or any of the synthetic
filters you might use,
which are just mainly made of
materials that have many small
holes in them and that's what
this tubule looks like.
So there is a filtration
function.
In order to perform this
filtration function,
I already mentioned that you
need to have pressure,
you got to have a pressure drop
in order to filter and that
pressure drop is generated by
the heart.
Here's an interesting thing,
we talked about pressure drop
in the circulation.
Remember when we talked before
spring break about where is the
main resistance to pressure or
to flow along the vessels of
your cardiovascular system.
Pressure is generated by the
heart, if we think about the
left side of the heart blood
flows into the aorta,
into large arteries,
arterioles, capillaries,
that's where exchange takes
place,
back into venules,
veins, back to the heart.
Where was the main pressure
drop, the main source of
resistance?
Which one of those elements had
the largest resistance,
do you remember?
Somebody--Brian did
you--Student:
[inaudible]Professor Mark
Saltzman: Capillaries have a
sizeable resistance but not the
most and it is important because
it's the place where--remember
size is regulated so that you
can adjust flow rates most
sensitively here;
in the arterioles or the small
arteries.
It turns out that the
glomerular capillaries or the
capillaries of these tufts sit
in the unique position between
two sets of arterioles.
Arteriole that leads into the
glomerulus and an arteriole that
leads out of the glomerulus.
Because of that if you have
this tuft of capillaries that's
sitting on either side of an
arteriole--now what did
arterioles do?
They were of the right size,
the right physical dimension so
that they created a fairly
substantial resistance to flow,
that's one thing.
They're the right size to
create a fairly substantial
resistance to flow and they can
expand and contract,
and so they can adjust their
resistance.
What happens when they adjust
their resistance?
They change the overall
pressure drop for that segment,
and by changing the pressure
drop you can change how much
flow occurs.
Well, the glomerular
capillaries sit here between two
arterioles and they can
independently regulate their
size.
What that allows the individual
nephron to do is to adjust
what's the pressure inside its
glomerular capillaries.
If I want the pressure to be
lower, then I squeeze in on this
one, the one that's leading in,
I get more of a pressure drop
across that arteriole so the
pressure's lower coming out.
If I want the higher pressure
drop on the glomerular
capillaries I expand this so
that I don't have as much
resistance,
I don't have as much of a
pressure drop,
I have higher pressure in the
glomerular capillaries.
Now, why would that make a
difference?
Because remember these
glomerular capillaries sit
inside this capsule where
there's a low pressure.
If I have high pressure here,
low pressure here,
I get filtration.
If pressure goes up inside here
but stays the same out here I
get more filtration;
if pressure goes down I get
less.
Every individual nephron has a
mechanism for regulating how
much fluid it filters at any
particular time,
and it does that by regulating
the arteries on either side of
the glomerular tuft.
I'm going to stop there and
then we'll continue next time
talking a little bit more detail
about how the kidneys do this
task of recovering molecules
that you need.
Questions?
Good, see you on Thursday.